Welcome to office hours for Unit 2.
We'll get started right away with questions.
Let's start with Catherine from New Hampshire.
She says, "I believe there were at least one or two instances where I
gave up in frustration and viewed a solution before getting a correct
answer in a unit quiz."
She wants to know, what do the unit quizzes mean?
Should she be concerned if she gets it right?
Should she be frustrated if she's getting them wrong?
I hope people aren't frustrated on the unit quizzes.
The quizzes in the units are really there to help keep you engaged--
to help you learn.
If you can't get the answer, that's okay that we do have
answers recorded after them.
You're not being graded on the quizzes.
They are really there to help you learn.
Some of the quizzes are harder than others.
One of the things that we do on the quizzes is rate them with gold stars.
Don't be surprised if you're not necessarily able to handle
those with gold stars.
Those are questions that will require a lot of thought.
Those are going to be really hard, especially for beginning students.
Those are questions that--I hope by thinking about them--you'll be
able to solve yourself.
If you're not able to solve it yourself, don't get frustrated.
You can watch the answer--hopefully you'll understand the answer--
and then maybe you'll be able to try it on your own again
after you've seen the answer.
The quizzes don't count towards your grade.
You shouldn't be frustrated or stressed about that.
They are really there to help you learn.